director Alex Price has given us a movie
that shows that love transcends death
itself and his pretty kick-ass and he
made it when he made the crow over 20
years ago what's happened in his life
since then to make him vomit out this
monstrosity I will never know but I can
guarantee you wasn't good gods of Egypt
so gods of Egypt is a really huge movie
about Egyptian mythology and the gods
exist they're real and they live among
the humans are twice the size of humans
are really huge they're really hard to
kill they're badasses and Gerard Butler
kills his brother and becomes King and
then Horus played by King Slayer from
Game of Thrones gets his eyes gouged out
and then this 99-cent version of Aladdin
alright I'm out I'm out I'm getting
bored
shitless even talking about it
one another plot go watch the movie
you're not going to after this so don't
even worry about it watch that wreck of
a trailer I'll save you some time
seriously this movie was a mess from
start to finish with a 99-cent GoBot
version of Aladdin hopped into his
girlfriend's chamber and started talking
I was like something is very wrong the
dialogue was clunky it was awkward he's
gonna plague the movie throughout then
boom a coup happens before you're even
attached to anything and then Aladdin
ish has to save the day with the help of
Horus first of all let's talk about what
I liked about the movie big pretty
things fire Lots done because that's it
about the Egyptian and all its huge
scale glory was pretty cool looking CGI
to death for sure was all the CGI good
no but it was pretty neat sometimes all
right so let's dissect the body of the
rest of it this movie was totally
unbalanced in the pacing was I mean
there's a scene pretty near the
beginning there's another scene also in
the movie were Aladdin ich has to solve
these puzzles and by puzzles I mean
there's like death traps think the end
of Indiana Jones and the Last Crusade
but in a couple different parts of this
movie
there's Indiana Jones and the Last
Crusade did it better because they built
the tension the audience was involved
what's the puzzle how do we do it oh my
gosh I'm biting my nails this movie's
like oh puzzle boo boo boo boom done no
real explanation doesn't give it time it
doesn't do what Hollywood you need to
know this it doesn't just our main
hero's solving the puzzle is a perfect
opportunity to engage the audience but
you didn't do it you don't buy any of
the love interest Gerard Butler's over
the top in a weird awkward dialogue kind
of way a few different times not just
Gerard Butler I mean Kingslayer a few
times a lot of people in this movie on a
few occasions had
one-liner they just had to say like this
snake is blowing fire and it blows up
and the fires coming towards him and of
course he has to snap out of quit before
he dodges it's not the time at that
point survived the fire first talk
later Gerard Butler has a couple of mr.
fries ish lines where I'm sure they were
supposed to sound really dick you know
like he was indifferent to human beings
like he was just kind of an and
he doesn't even get emotionally involved
but that's just an excuse people will
use for his character because it was
just sloppily written and sloppily done
this movie even does that transgression
where it's like there's something that
someone can't do I don't have the
ability to do that in the end they end
up spontaneously doing it and they're
like whoa I guess I could have done that
the whole time I'll be oh my god
Alex like not just the worst thing a
movie does I can think of worse but it's
up there the biggest bummer about this
movie is its Egyptian mythology it's
pretty lush it's pretty thick could have
been pretty sweet movie in the end you
had this boring slog fest of this God
and this mortal going on their quest
with big CGI huge scope and clunky ass
action oh my god anything talk about
that it's this action scene where
you can tell it was just like hey Jaime
Lannister make a pose there yeah perfect
alright do another one
alright yeah cool yeah we'll just CGI
around a lot the camera pan around you
and things will just happen we'll edit
around it this movie just lazy is clunky
it's uninteresting and in the end it
tied up in a messy ass sloppy ass wreck
of a bow to get people you alright later
bye leave the theatre now it's over
thanks for your money dicks Indian gods
of awful is certainly dog right so
gods of awful have you seen it what did
you think about it or what's your
biggest big-budget disappointment of all
time like the shittiest movie with the
big butt I don't even know what the
budget of this movie is it could be
nonsense it could be small I lack the
motivation to look it up myself but for
me the big budget movie will always
be Transformers Revenge of the Fallen
what got me started on here whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more